I don't want any
Who's there?
AH FUCK OFF!
Hello Everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome to RE77
Now, this is very confusing for me
because there was no title screen
on this game
and I just loaded up waking up here in
What i can only assume is a bed
Am I p-, yes I'm playing. Okay.
Hello
Hi
Oh
Hello!
Hi
Do I wanna go out there?
Oh that's probably important.
*mutters* Can I have that?
"middle mouse to zoom"
e... Okay!
Wait did I get it- OH!
I did get it
Ohhhhh
Hello!
HI!
Oh This is lovely!
And by lovely I mean horrifying
WOAH!
WOAH I just noticed that
There's like an impression of me in the bed!
It's kind of like the opening in portal 2
Okay, so that means I've been here a long time
long enough for the paint to start peeling off the walls
Hello!
Oh
Oh what a bright beautiful day!
and there's bars on the window!
Is that to keep me in or to keep other people out?
Where'd my flashlight go? Oh there it is.
Oh geez!
Oh geez
Hello princess, how you doin?
Oh. Ohhhh. OH!
I love the art!
Pitch Black like my soul!
Oh and x marks the spot apparently
Okay
uuhh
Oh. Okay, Nevermind then I'll go the other way
Supposedly that's gonna be better for me
Hello
Mmmm
This looks fun
I know I'm going to have a good time here!
I know everybody involved is going to have a good time
Oh at least this is art
Oh hello
What does that say?
Nine.... I don't know what that number is but
It's 1947 and i believe that's a nine at the beginning
IS THAT IMPORTANT?
Is that going to come into play later in the game?
and I think you're painting is upside down, not to criticize your artistic choices
Oh
Is this game inspired by P.T?
Cause this looks a lot like P.T
Cause like, isn't that like the exact same ..um..way there was a stairwell down
Wasn't it?
Ooh
Oh okay
Oh good!
Oh
*sarcastic enthusiasm* Ohhhhh yeah
*still sarcastic enthusiasm* Oh yeah
The ball changed colors I think
Okay so it is going to be sort of a looping hallway style P.T thing
Is that going to be anymore clear? No
Is there anymore writing on the wall that I need to be aware of?
Hello
Another X
Okie dokie then!
I can't wait for things to go topsy turvy all over
*weird noise*
Hi
Why'd ya do that?
Ow, that hurts my eyes
I'm getting outta here!
They're trying to kill me with light!
Darkness is my only friend
Okay
Hello?
Ah, good. yes.
Very good
Is it getting darker? I have a funny feeling it's getting darker
OOH!
Were you there before?
Oh..
I don't remember looking at these, but then again i might have just missed it but i
I don't think all this...Was this here before?
I don't quite remember it
Oh boy
HOO BOY
HOO BOY! hoo doggy
Okay
Well
Alright then
Ah yes
Good.
Why do I need to sprint?
WHY DO I NEED TO KNOW HOW TO SPRINT?
I DONT LIKE THAT!
I don't like it when games do that!
Give a nice soft subtle hint that I need to sprint
Holy shit
Oh god no
OH No, i don't wanna do this!
Oh man!
I love the interior decorating you've done!
Is there any like clue here?
I'm not very observant in these things
Many times I'll miss something
Ooo
Okay
Crumpled up paper is important? No? Yes? Maybe?
A lot of footprints on the floor
*whispers* A lotta footprints...whoah
Heeeeeeeey
Heeeeeeeeeeeeey
Heeeeeeey why is that moving?
*rumbling sound*
What the fuck was that?
WHY DOES A LOG NEED TO GO ZOOMING BY MY HEAD?
WHOSE DOING LUMBERWORK UPSTAIRS?
Oh good I'm glad I'm on a boat
*bird noises*
Why am I doing that?
WHY AM I DOING THAT?
THAT'S NOT NORMAL!
Is that why my head's shaking spastically? I think my shadows moving a little more then my head is!
GOOD GOD!
That's terrifying...
That's horrifying!
Oh my god! what is going on?
Why is this bouncing up against the princess door?
Is that where it was?
Do I need to go back in mine?
NOPE.
I don't need to go back to my room yet
Still time to play!
Woah boy
Okay
Oh geez oh geez oh geez
I know where I gotta go now
OH GEEZ
Oh geez scoob
Why's that locked too?
Is this where i need to learn how to sprint?
I THINK THIS IS WHERE I NEED TO LEARN TO SPRINT
OH GOD
Okay sprinting, GOODBYE
Scooby pleaseeeeee
Was that plant always there?
That plant was not always there.
Wait someone is dicking with me this plant was NOT here
What is gong on?
Wait a minute....
Someone is expressly dicking with me
I feel patently dicked with
OH COME ON
Oh don't be like that
Oh dont be like that. you're not just going to send me back and forth on a loop are ya?
Cause that plant was NOT there
I know for a FACT
I may be unobservant but I think I'd notice a plant suddenly appearing
What do i gotta go....
That's nothing, i thought I saw something
OH COME ON
WHAT AM I SUPPOSED TO DO
Am i just supposed to loop back and forth forever?
With my shakey head and my shakey bo-- why am I going so slow?
Why am I going so slow?
Oh that's slow I cant run anymore
Why
Okay
I don't know why that happened
OHHHHHHHH
OHHHH
OHHHH hello
Can I- oh. why is it so dark?
why is it so dark? Why? What is happening??
Did i do something?
Woah, kay?
what happened?
HUH?
WHAT'S HAPPENING?
The fuck?
"f to toggle flashlight" I DON'T WANNA
Oh.
OH!
Oh yeah that's nice!
Oh this is better
Ohh this is so much better
Okay so I was looping back and forth making up my own clues forever and ever like an idiot
When in reality, I was supposed to do a thing
I did not realize that
*intense banging* Fuck off, no thank you, I DONT WANT ANY
*garbled moaning noises*
Hello?
*garbled sobbing noise*
Okay
Uhhhh no thank you
So in my imagination, I created a clue out of a plant, a bone that i didn't notice,
and everything, and I was running back and forth for a WHILE like an idiot
when uh... in reality...I wasn't supposed to do that
*crying behind Mark...*
I don't want any
I don't want any, I dont want any
Whose there?
AH FUCK OFF!
*panting*
Fuck you
nnnnnnnnNNNNNNNNOOOOOOOOOOO
Okay well at least my flashlight is back to NormAL
And the ball is over there for some reason
So the trick was zooming in, i don't know if I actually mentioned that
So i needed to zoom in
So uh.. so that's what i forgot in the beginning of the game
was the whole zooming aspect of it
Well,*unintelligible gibberish* ugh
UGH
Eugh!
Why?
EW
That's not normAL
What am i supposed to do about that?
I don't think I'm supposed to do anything about that.
I think I need to stop that
Oh geez.
Is that just going to keep oozing?
It's so oozy
Oh it's so oozy
Okay
Welp, Nope I can't do anything about it!
I guess I'll just carry on
Wherever the hell else I'm supposed to go in this game
Can I go down in the hallway now, or am I stuck in here again?
Oh. OHHHH. PROGRESS!!! My god, beautiful, beautiful progress.
Oh I can't wait to have my soul ripped out from my heart
Is it raining?
Still goopy!
Still nice and goopy
Alright
Okay
So everything seems about the same
Oh and that's open too!
Oh what is that?
theeeewwweeerreeaurrrreeeewahhh..They're watching us!
Oh okay, who, and why, and how?
So is this special in any---ah E
*static* *footstep thumping sounds in background*
I FEEL A LOOOT BETTER
Should i look at the bone maybe?....
Nope that bone is not interesting enough
Okay bye!
I'm gonna go now!
Awaaaaaaaaaay
from youuuuuuuuu
Ehhh
Man this game,
Oh hello, oh
Something seems different
Something seems-- oh is it even goopier? Oh it's even goopier than before!
Great
Oh! I was hoping for a bunch of extra goop!
s'what i need in my life
*creepy woman crying*
*calmly* Shut the fuck up
SHUT UP!
Who's doing that?
Huh?
Someone better not be crying.....
YOU KNOW WHAT I DO TO PEOPLE THAT CRY???
I CRY WITH THEM
Then i cry harder and beat them at their own game of crying
like a bitch
No one cries like Markimoo
Okay
Alright
Well this seems roughly the same as before
Am I supposed to do a thing?
Well that's, that's pleasant. That's pleasant that is.
That's nice AND pleasant
Oh boy
I have a funny feeling it's going to loop me through the same section until I figure out what to do
with all the goop
you all right in there?
It's going to keep looping for a bit I guess
Why are you crying?
Different color again...
It is a different color...
*jumpscare*
AHHH FUUCK!!!!
FUUUUCK YOU OKAY?
YOU THINK YOU CAN JUST DO THAT?
HUH?
YOU THINK??
THAT'S ALLOWED?????
Well i guess that's the end of that
That's just the demo, or the pre- alpha I don't know!
It's early!
So that was RE77
I got spooped
So anyway, this game was actually really, like, really, really well made
I mean, there has been a lot of games that try to be P.T
This is by far the closest
I mean it was a bit hard to figure out, just cause I was an idiot,
but that doesn't mean it was any sort of bad.
It got me in this mode where I was looking desperately for everything
and I was making things out of nothing
and that's cool
that's something you very rarely see in a game, where you are so engrossed in what it is
that you're trying to come up with any way to rationalize what's happening.
SO either way, that was this game.
Let me know what you thought of it down in the comments below and thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always, I will see you, in the next video
BUH-BYE!!!